so I think I think in a course like this
assessment is tricky that these are
individual clients and projects and we
can try to standardize maybe the design
and engineering challenge to some extent
but that's not necessarily what we took
as our primary consideration we really
started with the people first and tried
to match people to projects and there's
no doubt there are some projects that
are more technically involved there are
some projects with logistics or more
difficult meeting with the client or
even working with with him or her or
even within the within the team so it is
a tricky kind of thing but I think
having us as instructors very involved
in the class and getting a sense of all
the projects having the mentors really
have a strong understanding of different
projects progress so we had one mentor
for every two teams was really key to
the assessment kind of a high-level we
had different pieces over the course of
the semester so doing this midterm
design review counts as part of the
assessment certainly the final
presentations the documentation is a big
part but we also rely on a mentor
feedback client feedback we met we met
with all the clients at the end of the
semester as well as peer feedback you
know this is a team-based project course
so taking into all of these taking in
all these inputs is what we tried to do
when it came to assessment to really try
to understand what students have learned
and how they performed in the in the
course so for some of these we did
prepare rubric or we had a vague sense
of what we were looking for so for
example for the blog post we would score
it based on
just like how weld did you write it in
grammar and how much information is
there but we're looking for really deep
personal reflection and so that's what
you know we gave distinctiveness points4
i believe and so for example you know
you could have a post just on assistive
dogs and what types of assistive dogs
are there which is great it shows that a
student is learning but another post one
of my favorite posts actually over the
semester was from one of my students who
was kind of struggling with should i go
into assistive technology as a career
when everyone is saying you should do
something that's lucrative but this is
like beneficial but what if you know
beneficial isn't profitable what happens
then and she was really struggling with
like am i a selfish person things like
that answer that kind of very deep press
no growth is is something that I valued
a lot I think end up yeah we all valued
a lot um and yeah there's actually very
little weight put on the final project
we put a lot of weight on how well did
they go about the design process and so
how many prototypes what did I manage to
do when they didn't have the skills to
do a certain project were they able to
go look for resources did they go around
MIT knocking on doors asking for
professors for help asking machine shop
technicians for help and that was that
was also highly valued I'm and then what
else do you think I'm missing
we also take into account when the
clients were so some clients would
changed your mind about what project
they wanted the students to work on over
the course of semester which is really
difficult for the students because they
would make progress on something I
didn't have to you know change the
project direction completely and so we
would try and take that into account as
well like how were the students able to
manage that and so because of these kind
of little things you know we really
didn't put a lot of weight on how the
project turned out and every day was
more about how much effort you planted
it how much did you grow as a person how
well did you manage your clients
expectations and yeah were you able to
satisfy the client given all the
constraints so very very organic which
is why we had to spread out the grading
rubric across lots of little components
and that's why we had to get feedback
from mentors and peers and clients and
have mid semester reviews and final
semester reviews and yeah it was I hope
I explained yeah I think I think there's
a lot of aspects to this one is you know
we really did try to structure the
evaluation as much as possible in terms
of being able to try to grade
objectively and so we did have a decent
number of structured rubrics that were
happy to share in terms of how we
evaluated different components of the
project so everything from the blogger
from bump of the course everything from
the blog posts to the videos to the mid
semester final semester panels the
documentation
all aspects of the of the class I think
we for for kind of the individual
components really as what grace says
really trying to personalize the
learning a little bit in terms of having
reflections or blog posts where people
could write about topics that interested
them as it related to assistive
technology I think that's something that
we tried this year as opposed to maybe
more sort of form kind of lab reports on
some of the labs that we did or
something like that the other part I
think we we tried this year was really
to take in as grace is saying all of
these kind of human inputs or feedback
so we met weekly as a staff and kind of
reflected on the projects and students
progress we talked to clients and you
know had students themselves talk a
little bit about their their peers and
so that's I think what we tried to take
into account i think we tried to some
extent we tried to start from what would
be sort of ideal in terms of
understanding students experiences in
the class and that i think makes it a
little bit tricky to evaluate or grade
but hopefully you know it's sort of the
sort of one reasonable way or one you
know valuable way to do it